[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Carol west and today is a very special
day because it's shahboz birthday it's
my birthday it's my birthday and also I
got a chance to pick up a statue just
today now you don't know I had a box
there that was supposed to be displayed
and every time I go to put a box up
something else pops up well today is the
kind of a weird day because I didn't
know what's that's what I was going to
do for my birthday and I said you know
what um I'm going to do an Incredible
Hulk statue because I have plenty of
Incredible Hulk statues that I haven't
displayed yet and I had the whole
thought pattern in my head I had the
whole story in Scenario of which one I
was going to do and what I was going to
talk about and I decided to go to face
book marketplace and I went to the
marketplace just to get one go around
just to look look see and lo and behold
I saw sideshows Heatseeker Premium
Format Deadpool for an incredible price
shout out to mo Martinez for making sure
that I was able to get this piece he
helps a piece for me until the next day
met up with him
a great dude a great part of our
community and I can't state it enough
that he's a honorable dude great to do
business with upstanding dude all right
so shout out to you mole
for making sure that I had a fantastic
birthday unboxing with this statue that
I have before me no let me start off by
saying I am NOT a fan of rob life never
been I don't think I ever would be you
know I come from great artists like John
Byrne John Romita Jr George Perez Ron
Lim you know and so on Southview Simha I
can go on and on Jack Kirby I can go on
and on with the legendary and
inspirational artists that I grew up
with Todd McFarlane who I know
personally that's right I'm dropping
names um and again you know Rob Liefeld
came along and he invented some of our
great Marvel characters not taking away
from his genius not taking away from
that young vision that the characters
that he had in his head that he wanted
to bring out but with that being said I
thought like when I was younger I
thought Deadpool was a knockoff of like
spider-man somewhere dude so I really
didn't care you never read the books for
him
didn't think that he was anything that I
cared about
until I saw Ryan Reynolds go so hard for
this character I mean Ryan Reynolds
shout-out to Ryan Reynolds for bringing
that character to the big screen
I'm pushing as hard as he did to get
that character out and made it a thing
now I'm anticipating the Deadpool movie
3 because of Ryan Reynolds sorry
Williams lipped about said Rob Liefeld
but um definitely 100% he got me looking
into the character then I looked at a
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe I
looked at Deadpool vs. Thanos and all of
the
wonderful stories that I was put off
from because I didn't like ripe rough
black people's part and other artists
got a chance to get a hold of the
character found out that he was part of
the same what the next program is what
Raymond
he has healing powers that are on poor
on par with Wolverine if not rivals his
healing ability like Sabretooth so he's
very intricate and when it comes to the
x-men they tie him into that universe
and if your x-men fan then you know
pretty much Deadpool has been like a
staple in that universe so let's get to
the statue right because this statue is
probably one of the single characters
that I was not checking for but it does
so many different things in one statue
so damn well that you must stand up and
admire it the base alone has a clear
resin that looks like they threw it when
a door blew it up buddy
he was in the middle of a fight and he's
dancing around a rocket launch that his
body that is packed the size of his body
while slashing a grenade in half at the
same time he's shooting behind the head
blowing a kiss this is the es version
this version comes with two heads
I thought the basic head it was basic
this the second head comes like he's
blowing a kiss as you can see here and
then you can move the gun and put a
selfie stick he's taking a picture with
his cell phone
in the midst of battle if that's not
Deadpool if that's not whimsical comedy
comedic fun at its best
so poles is crazy the body is extended
this is full extension so you must have
a pack sore or something big enough to
put this in or standalone space like
most sanity you had to make space it was
nothing wrong with the statue is just he
had to make space now and I understand
well I found a space for this bad boy
here another thing that I found
supremely interesting there like other
companies like XM sideshow made sure
that they gave you an assembly cheap
because you will need it well this is
the part of the video when I'm gonna
tell you to like follow subscribe and
also hit the joy button hit that joy
button you know what that joint button
is it's right there at the bottom hit
that joint button so you can see all the
wonderful things that iron Lords
podcasts that I'm a member of does in
the realm and also go to laws of gaming
net well we have a ton of opinion pieces
mods gaming is on the forefront right
now of bringing you every last bit of
information of these next-gen consoles
from the Xbox series X to the Lockhart
the one that's in shrouded in mystery to
the PlayStation 5 and all the
accessories he's giving you details
specs and he's giving you the rundown so
please tune in to Lords of gaming dotnet
and read up on mods and watches as I
watch this videos videos is top notch
also last word with Lord Cognito any
bonta's these guys are doing things and
destiny community that I it's unheard of
they're bringing your favorite
streamers and your favorite destiny
players and bloggers to the show to give
their insights so if you want to know
everything about destiny
I suggest you tune to the last word with
loyal kognito any bonta's well I'm gonna
take off air but I want you to stick
around watch the video without this guy
talking and next week I forgive you that
statue that has been highly elusive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]